as a lie that all drivers tell  themselves death is something that  happens to other people what kind of  person does a job like this each year  two of us die James give a list Ellen  make his genius setting up the cars  I accept every time I get a mecha  there's 20% chance I could die being  driven around 170 miles per hour this is  a bomb on wheels and quicker than all of  you and let's race  I feel responsible for what happened  you were a trestle watching your windows  races you were equally responsible for  getting me back at the car  I'm world champion from the verge to  become world champion again this time  trust me  it's a wonderful way to live  is the only way to drive  the closer you are to death the more  alive you feel